ballon perd du shoot raté le public
orléanis a vu son équipe à la peine hier
soir et Boulogne en noir emmené Parcker
meilleur marqueur avec 25 points a pris
confiance le temps d'un match match que
la lanterne rouge du championnat va
mener quasiment de bout en bout côté OLB
la tâche du nouvel entraîneur Pierre
Vincent n'était pas simple arrivé mardi
n'a dirigé que TR entraînements avec sa
nouvelle équipe ses joueurs ont été
volontaire mais un peu
perdu sur le
match j'ai perçu ce sentiment là de
doute de difficulté qui les voil les
a détruit quoi quelque part parce qu'on
on perd pas beaucoup de ball mais on en
perd certaines grossièr situation de
Pier facile leur Mar Antoine PEL tenté
de maintenir la barque à fl mais
offensivement orlé éta trop faible 20%
de réussite à 3 points moins de 50% à de
POS c'était insuffisant pour contrer
Boulogne ravi de ne prendre que 79
points et d'en marquer 86
en perdant ce soir on aurait quasiment
été mort donc quasiment non seulement on
le gagne mais en plus on prend le petit
le petit point le petit point qui peut
qui peut être important en fin de saison
donc c'estàd le goage donc alors
attention on reste les gabl on reste
dans fond du classement mais on reste en
vie on reste en vie confirmation
Boulogne est toujours dernier du
championnat en position relégable execo
avec bouran Bress mais Orléan ne compte
plus qu'une victoire d'avance sur ces
deux équipes aujourd'hui il y avait un
tel enjeu que les joueurs étaient tendus
mais au-delà du des joueurs en fait
l'ensemble du public était tendu il y a
des moments difficiles il y a des
erreurs qui sont faites les erreurs les
joueurs ne le font pas exprès évidemment
et donc dans ces cas-là ben euh le fait
d'avoir un soutien ben peut le leur
donner un peu plus confiance qu'ils
n'ont aujourd'hui au les cœur il reste à
Orléan et Boulogne 13 matchs pour faire
perdurer le rêve d'un maintien en proie